wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
gehst du gerne ins theater
eigentlich schon aber ich habe kaum zeit
entschuldigung ich habe nur wiederholt
ach so das thema eine lektion ist
theater kunst und kultur
es geht um literatur theater und malerei
es geht aber auch um gedichte und romane
naja interessierst dich nicht für kultur
hier ganz gerne ins kino aber theater
finde ich ziemlich langweilig was mit
musik interessiert die musik total bist
du schon mal auf einem festival gewesen
aber ich möchte nächsten sommer
unbedingt auf ein open air festival
gehen
[Musik]
die band hat abgesagt was jetzt unsere
gäste kommen schon in ein paar stunden
ja ich weiß aber der sänger ist krank
welche band das restaurant hat doch
zehnjähriges jubiläum und wir haben
dafür eine band bestellt jetzt haben wir
kein programm so kurzfristig finden wir
kein nein nein auf keinen fall
nico